[Music]
mjolnir has always been a huge part of
thor's adventures and thor love and
thunder is certainly no exception but
what's the history behind thor's magical
hammer and what does mjolnir even mean
keep watching to find out
one of mjolnir's most distinctive
features is its short handle but there's
a lot more to mjolnir's length than you
might expect the story behind mjolnir's
creation as well as its unique
appearance goes as far back as the
original norse myths and loki's penchant
for mischief in the midst of a much
larger tale about loki stealing the hair
of thor's wife sif loki commissions two
dwarfs to create three magical gifts for
the gods to up the stakes loki bets his
head that the two couldn't make gifts as
good as the dwarfs who made sif's
replacement hair to ensure that he keeps
his head loki transforms into a fly and
bites one of the dwarfs while he makes
mjolnir resulting in the hammer coming
out with a shorter handle than intended
despite its top-heavy appearance it was
still mighty and balanced and the
mythological thor cherished it all the
same while the mythological origins of
mjolnir weren't carried over into marvel
perfectly intact with the comic version
being crafted out of a fictional medal
called uru in a dying star in one
version of the origin story it is
interesting to see how the myths
influenced the design in the comics
it was a major moment in avengers end
game when fans finally saw captain
america wield mjolnir proving once and
for all that he truly is worthy of the
power of thor whosoever holds of this
hammer
if he be worthy shall possess the power
of thought
it was a plot moment that was multiple
movies in the making with cap's
worthiness being teased way back at the
beginning of avengers age of ultron
however as many marvel mega fans already
know captain america is far from the
only superhero worthy of wielding the
hammer
i knew it
aside from cap and vision who briefly
wielded the hammer in age of ultron the
marvel database actually lists dozens of
characters who are able to hold mjolnir
these include other asgardians like odin
and boer familiar characters like jane
foster and black panther and even mcu up
and comers like moon knight those
unfamiliar with moon knight's lore might
be confused as to how a somewhat
unhinged vigilante with multiple
personalities could be worthy of thor's
hammer however thanks to konshu the
ancient egyptian moon god whom moon
knight serves moon knight can hold and
even control mjolnir because uru is
technically made of moon rock
lightning flying and hitting things
really hard are the powers most people
would associate with mjolnir
what am i looking at oh sometimes it
takes a second
however mjolnir is capable of much more
than summoning lightning and smashing
bad guys much like how superman once had
some odd powers he no longer uses
mjolnir has a similar tendency to do
whatever the writer needs it to at that
moment just to name a few examples of
this mjolnir can open wormholes to
instantly travel across the universe
turn thor or others invisible manipulate
people's souls translate everything thor
says into any language he needs and
sense energy signatures of course none
of those powers quite replace bonking
people on the head and shooting them
with lightning in most situations which
is why you still primarily see thor
using those abilities in battle
nevertheless it's important to remember
that mjolnir is still one of the most
powerful and versatile weapons in the
universe therefore thor is likely much
more versatile than most comics and mcu
fans would give him credit for he's
certainly more than just a hunk of
muscle and lightning
a lot has happened to both thor and
mjolnir in recent comics from becoming
unworthy and allowing the mantle of thor
to be carried by jane foster to seeing
jane sacrifice both herself and the
hammer to finally reforging the hammer
so that thor could use it in the war of
the realms mjolnir has seen a lot of
change what nobody ever expected however
was for the hammer to wake up of course
mjolnir had always been somewhat alive
one version of its comic book origin
story reveals that odin trapped the god
tempest in the uru that would become
mjolnir upon being reforged however the
god tempest's essence combined with that
of mangog a being who despised asgard
for the genocide of its people thus
mjolnir was able to create its own
avatar one that no longer cared for thor
or asgard and only desired death and
destruction dubbing itself the god of
hammers
mjolnir showed some cool new abilities
in thor love and thunder including the
power to reassemble itself from its
shattered uru metal shards and then
temporarily disassemble itself again to
attack an enemy from all directions but
did you know those pieces of mjolnir can
become entirely new hammers in the
comics this came in handy for puddle
gulp one of thor's more unusual friends
who first appeared in thor number 364.
once a man by the name of simon
walterson who was transformed into a
frog by a curse puddle gulp was adopted
by new york's secret frog kingdom and
fought against a rival rat army
alongside thor when the thunder god was
transformed into a frog by loki puddle
gulp revealed his true identity to thor
and watched as the frog of thunder
lifted mjolnir transforming into a giant
frog in thor's armor unknown to thor a
sliver of mjolnir had broken off the
hammer and when puddle gulp proved
worthy enough to lift the shard of uber
metal it transformed into the mighty
frogule near and turned the enchanted
frog into throg frog of thunder throg
used his asgardian powers to protect the
frogs of central park and eventually
went on to team up with other animal
superhero sidekicks to form the pet
avengers weird as this story might sound
if mjolnir really is a sentient being it
stands to reason that it can reproduce
and make new enchanted hammers for the
worthy including frogs
fans have been struggling with the
proper pronunciation of mjolnir for
decades once you figure it out however
an even more relevant question comes up
what does mjolnir actually mean let's
explore
let's bring the rainbow
most scholars trace the name mjolnir
back to old slavic russian and welsh
terms which all translate into the word
lightning as thor's own name goes back
to a proto-germanic root meaning thunder
this seems appropriate however some
scholars also point out that mjolnir may
be related to the icelandic words
meaning new snow and white both symbols
of purity this could relate to the way
thor's hammer was often used in rituals
like marriage effectively purifying
those it blessed mjolnir may also be
derived from a proto-germanic word which
translates into to grind this could mean
mjolnir was known as the grinder or the
crusher two things it's still known for
doing today in the marvel universe
so our variants show up in multiple
fictional universes and dc comics has
its own thor who wields his own mighty
hammer however it's actually marvel's
version of mjolnir that caused two dc
icons superman and wonder woman to share
a special bond superman got to wield
mjolnir in the dc marvel crossover
miniseries jla avengers the story saw
marvel's avengers and dc's justice
league come to blows and eventually team
up to save their universes from mutual
destruction in the final battle thor
passed his hammer to superman who found
his power magnified beyond imagination
by mjolnir's magic curiously the man of
steel found he could no longer lift the
hammer following the battle although
thor assured him mjolnir was in good
hands for the brief time he wielded it
wonder woman found herself worthy to
lift mjolnir in the dc versus marvel
crossover event when she came across it
following thor's battle with captain
marvel
shazam although the hammer increased
wonder woman's power to insane levels
diana decided to fight without it when
she was matched up with storm feeling
mjolnir's magic would give her an unfair
advantage later she politely handed the
hammer back to a perplexed thor although
these crossover events would fade in and
out of memory both superman and wonder
woman are remembered as worthy wielders
of mjolnir in thor the worthy when jane
foster's thor glimpses the man of steel
and amazon princess among the worthy
superman himself indicates he recalls
these events in superman volume 2 number
165 when he gives diana a gold pendant
shaped like mjolnir as a christmas gift
recognizing their unique bond
mjolnir is a mighty weapon but some fans
forget that it's also something far more
than just a weapon since the asgardians
were once worshiped as gods mjolnir is
considered a religious item meaning it
is particularly dangerous against
supernatural entities like vampires and
the undead
in thor number 332 fans see just why
vampires should be afraid of mjolnir
when thor goes up against some
blood-sucking fiends serving dracula
upon seeing a vampire attack a woman
thor throws his hammer at him causing
the creature to burst into flame and
transform into dust the second mjolnir
touches him the hammer proves equally
effective when thor dusts some giant
vampire bats a few panels later
unfortunately when thor attempts to use
mjolnir against dracula himself in the
next issue the vampire lord gets
teleported away
as is the case with a lot of godlike
superheroes thor possesses the power of
flight unlike superman or wonder woman
however the god of thunder has a very
specific means of getting airborne he
spins mjolnir really fast and then
launches it skyward using its forward
momentum to pull him into the air as it
turns out this unique means of flight
was devised by stan lee to get around
what he saw as a common fallacy among
flying superheroes they had no visible
means of propulsion in one of his videos
for stan's rants lee revealed that when
thor wants to fly quote we use a
scientific principle explaining how his
use of hammer propulsion provided a
scientifically sound explanation for
thor's flight over the years however
various artists have shown thor flying
without mjolnir in superman type poses
calling into question whether thor
actually needs his hammer to fly
nevertheless science writer kyle hill
proposes in his scientific american
article the god of thunder and momentum
that mjolnir could conceivably drag a
much lighter thor through space if it
made itself incredibly heavy something
that also explains how mjolnir could
keep the unworthy from lifting it who
knew stan lee was such a science genius
that's it no more rant goodbye check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the mcu
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]